[Applause]
one two three
thank you I think I think y'all just got
more Applause than the Rocks
I'm not joking
is more powerful than the Rockets
[Applause]
did y'all all meet like when did you all
meet obviously not the first time you
did the show right like mixed first time
I met Cheryl was at a an event an AIDS
event I think it was Broadway cares but
out here and you were sitting at my
table and the first thing you did was
introduce me to your husband I was like
oh generally Ralph I'm such a fan and
she said have you met my husband
and I said This Woman's gonna stay
married a long time
the first time I met Lisa was on set for
the pilot and it was she um you know
auditioned for the pilot so I met her
via that ever kind of first our first
table read which was over Zoom but the
first time was really doing the show I
was just a fan of her and a fan of her
comedic career so yeah I was just like
honored to to be talking to her and then
when did y'all first meet the first time
I met Quinta the first time I actually
met Quinta was on this one of the CBS oh
my God okay I know if you were going to
say that yeah the CBS lights and you had
just sold one of your first shows and my
daughter and I were walking across the
lot and my daughter Coco says Mommy
that's Quinta Brunson and she's gonna be
big you have to meet her she was right
Coco did like called it yes he found it
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]